(audience cheering)
- That was... Now, I know
from our last interview
that you're a great singer,
but that is awesome.
I loved your whole song.
- Well, you know, desperate times, right?
- No, those are just regular great times.
- Well, the show's been
on the air 20 years.
- Geez.
- Oh my gosh.
- And so...
(audience cheering)
- I did not realize.
- That's the year that you won.
- I was gonna say 20 years.
You are a fan.
(laughing)
- 'Cause I used to wear this
pink ring every time you sang,
and I was pretty sure-
- It was you.
20 years, though. Longevity
is hard in this career.
- It's super weird.
I mean, "Dirty Jobs" has been on 20,
"Deadliest Catch" has been on 19.
- Wow
- Which I'm still doing.
So I think in this
industry, everybody's...
You look for hits and
you look for what's new.
And the thing I was really
fortunate to stumble across
were shows that had big themes under them.
So it's all kinda the same.
It's just me tapping the country
on the shoulder every week
saying, "What about her?
"What about him?
"Get a load of that."
- Which is so cool.
- And people still
watch, it's unbelievable.
- Yeah.
- I mean, I'm castrating cats
on international television
and people are watching.
- Of course, we are.
- Why would we not?
- Why? Yeah.
- I had a ball
(laughing)
- You had a ball?
That was really good.
Wait, have y'all ever met?
Zoe, have y'all ever met? Okay.
- No. But I feel like I've
known you for like two minutes.
- Two minutes.
A solid five minutes.
So wait, did you ever
get in a scary situation
with "Dirty Jobs" where you were like,
"Ah, this is too far?"
- Only every day for 20 years.
- Okay.
- I mean, my job on that show,
I mean, if you haven't seen it,
is to essentially assume the
identity of an apprentice.
So it's Groundhog's Day for me every day.
It's the first day on the job.
- What's like the scariest, though?
- Well, if you gotta thing for heights,
you probably don't wanna be
on top of the Mackinac Bridge
or a radio tower changing light bulbs.
- I don't have a thing
for... I don't mind heights,
but I still don't wanna do it.
- If you have a thing for tight places,
you probably don't wanna opal mine.
You probably don't wanna be
in some of these crazy jammed up places,
a mile below the earth's surface.
- Nope.
- So you never know what
you're gonna get on the show
except for an honest look at work.
(audience laughing)
Why are they laughing? What happened?
Did something bad happen?
- Her face.
(laughing)
- Oh, okay.
- Crossing bridge.
- No, but it's true.
Zoe, so like you were talking
about jumping out of a plane.
So I mean, that's a great example.
I jumped out of a plane
with the Golden Knights
who were essentially the
sort of the Blue Angels
of the army.
- I've done the Blue Angel thing, yeah.
- Praying paratroopers.
And yeah, the first time you
go out and pull your own shoot
is a moment that you're never, ever, ever,
ever, ever, ever, ever gonna forget.
- Or never, ever, ever, ever have.
- Yeah.
It makes an impression.
But that's the the point of the show,
it's not to be an adrenaline junkie,
it's just to show people,
"Look, these are the people
"who are building our world.
"They're tending to our civilization.
"This is what they do every single day."
Now I've done it for 20 years,
but in the end I go home, I take a shower,
I come, I do your show,
I sing "Deck The Halls"
and get on with my life.
- But this is their every day.
- This is the world we live in.
And without these folks,
party's over. Right?
Plumbers, steam fitters, pipe fitters.
- I think we all figured
that out during COVID
when nobody could come to the house.
- Real quick.
- Yeah.
- Well, that's why "Dirty Jobs" came back.
Essential work suddenly
became headline news.
And now everybody's talking
about the definition
of what it means to have an essential job,
what it means to work.
So, you know, not to overthink it.
- And what we took for granted.
- And what we take for granted every day.
- Yeah. Agreed.
Ugh, like indoor plumbing.
I had to do a lot of things in
a forest I did not wanna do.